buonasera buonasera
no no flight fotografie e niente del
genere perché il ponte forse lo
conoscete molto bene vorrei allacciamo
un attimo i miei predecessori hanno
fatto tutta una serie di relazioni e
molto interessanti devo dire è anche
stimolanti perché io in realtà volevo
parlare partendo da più che
dall'universo dallo spazio che già nello
stato molto bene i relatori a uno spazio
ridottissimo che è in realtà il nostro
spazio interno cioè il nostro essere
umani è un microcosmo ovverosia e uno
spazio ridotto come dimensioni ma è
enorme in espansione verso l'esterno
verso un cosmo molto più grande e quindi
proprio da questo siamo secondo me
legati a quelle opere che noi stessi
realizziamo e che realizzano i nostri
padrino figli nel futuro i nostri
progettisti me compreso con colpe e con
meriti nel tempo noi siamo sempre alla
ricerca di qualcosa
noi siamo spinti da dentro da delle dei
valori che sono la bellezza
ho sentito parlare benissimo di amore di
scienza perché la scienza è diciamo la
cognizione intellettuale per cui noi
ragioniamo e affrontiamo i problemi
della vita
in questo senso l'opera del ponte
contiene un po tutto questo ho sentito
dire che il ponte suscita sgomento
suscita attrazione suscita interesse per
i ragazzi che vanno a dipingere suscita
interesse per chi vuole andare in
bicicletta fare degli esperimenti
incredibili trasforma il ponte in una
struttura che va al di là della nostra
immaginazione come l'immaginazione è
l'opera d'arte in sé c'è l'opera d'arte
è vista da noi con un significato che
non li diamo c'è il nostro microcosmo
legge una cosa lì da il valore a questa
cosa quindi diciamo anche se fosse una
brutta struttura o un pezzo di città che
noi critichiamo in realtà dentro a
abbiamo sentito parlare di animano
quindi anche un'anima degna di essere
rispettata e posso dire stimolata anche
nel cambiamento questo senso penso a
potenza che ha sì ponte musmeci
importante ma ha delle potenzialità
future che secondo me vanno visti da
ognuno di noi con un occhio sensibile
che parte da dentro di noi ha una
coscienza per cioè la coscienza di fare
un progetto una previsione per la nostra
comunità che sia un futuro sicuramente
migliore di trasformazione di quelle
brutture che magari esistono ma anche di
quelle cose belle
il ponte stesso è un esempio mi voglio
soffermare rapidamente sui tuoi problemi
di manutenzione ma ai problemi
manutenzione
secondo me devo essere risolti con
l'interesse di tutti anche dei cittadini
più semplici che devono fornire il loro
apporto sensibile agli amministratori i
quali devono ascoltare questa cosa come
devono ascoltare tutto il resto cioè
questa fusione tra le cose belle e le
cose brutte ci deve essere perchè non
possiamo dire più demolisco no come si
diceva all'inizio una cosa perchè è
brutta la devo trasformare come potenza
la grande potenza di scusate il gioco di
parole di poter sviluppare uno spazio
nuovo con qualità
migliore legando il ponte alla città ma
non solo fisicamente anche con la testa
e con la coscienza di tutti quanti
chi viene da fuori e chi sta dentro
quindi io sono molto contento di questa
iniziativa del test che parla di
bellezza di bruttezza di possibilità di
potenza di crescere da un punto di vista
estetico ma anche di qualità perché la
qualità dobbiamo creare noi sta dentro
di noi
ognuno di noi anche le persone capitano
qui che secondo motivo è ma quelle sono
case popolari no sono persone come noi
tutte hanno una coscienza e hanno una
responsabilità della propria vita della
qualità della propria vita e quindi
dobbiamo guardare fuori di sé e dire
signori bisogna reagire in qualche modo
siamo noi i fautori della nostra vita e
noi siamo i responsabili
poi esistono di amministrazioni esistono
i tecnici progettisti e ognuno si deve
prendere proprio responsabilità finisco
con dire una cosa che l'insegnamento
tecnico di musmeci e ingegneristico di
qui è matematico
quindi lo lascerei un attimo stare
lascerei l'insegnamento teorico
filosofico di musmeci di sergio che era
diciamo spinto dalla ricerca continua di
qualcosa di me e di meglio
ovverosia ieri ha fatto una cosa e
domani potrebbe essere ancora meglio
quindi ricercare sempre con coscienza
chiaramente quindi educazione
dentro di sé nello studio nella ricerca
per perde diciamo sviluppare un futuro
migliore un futuro responsabile
un futuro che avesse un senso perché
tutte queste cose che messe insieme i
valori che noi ci siamo sempre tenuti
solo su quel ponte il senso strutturale
il senso estetico il senso dell'arte il
senso fisico il senso ludico perché
abbiamo visto che ci si gioca sopra il
senso infrastrutturale perché ci si
cammina incollato mobili quindi è un
esempio che tutti quanti noi dobbiamo
portare per il nostro futuro e unirlo
con potenza con delle strutture che
possono essere la natura del parco della
basentana del fiume la città stessa
perché viene collegata a lui a insistere
su questa strada
siete ricchi di una cosa rarissima che è
un'opera d'arte signor